Welcome everybody to another Zoom call. Remember to
chat in your questions if you have them or you think of new questions
or you were able to submit a question for some reason.
And wherever you can always submit more than one question.
There's no limit for saying that somebody submits 12 questions
and when I get them all in, but we want you to get most of your questions answered.
Alright, so let's get going with this. Remember to look at the announcements.
There wasn't that I didn't post any new announcements this week.
I did post some new videos on the site.
And wherever you could schedule follow up,
calls if you have any personal chat with me about let's get to the first question.
Is it normal that I could barely see any light coming from the plasma ball?
So if you're ready, the true right.
There's higher frequencies. It's really hard to see the light.
Well, the true right, the small, the new smaller ball.
So everybody's got different equipment here.
So some people that have the true right with the larger ball.
It was often much more difficult to see the light because it's dispersed through that globe.
So that was an issue.
People that are ready to tell you a robin.
If you're programmable, we're ready to 11th harmonic frequencies.
They are really difficult to see the light through that ball.
Typically, people that are running the true right with the small, the shorter ball,
which is considered true rights newer bulb.
It doesn't have as much gas in it.
And it will.
It will light brighter.
Typically.
So the larger.
I think better bulbs, the earlier true right bulbs and the current.
The new bulbs that we created for it until the orbit.
And especially if you're ready to hire frequencies or even more especially if you're running.
The 11th harmonic frequencies.
You could hardly see.
The light.
I mean, you might square during a daylight time.
There's no light coming out of this ball, especially the crystal balls.
You can't see it.
You'd have to literally put it in a dark room to see the light coming out of it.
And that was intentional.
So the biggest complaints that we had over the years is that the light would keep them up.
We don't want so much light.
Still getting the frequencies through the light.
Carried out of photon.
But it's not as bright.
Because the new.
The new bulbs that we have are the.
The old gas combination as well, which aren't going to light as bright.
So it's a little more expensive gas combination.
Which.
So how much technical physics things with that, but it could be more beneficial.
Yes, the answer is it's normal that you can barely see any light, especially at higher frequencies.
And especially if you're ready to level.
Next question is using hot greed tea instead of frozen berries in the shaker smoothie that you recommended.
OK, or are the berries required with the counters?
Nope.
You could make it a hot drink if you want.
That's just fine as well.
So.
I've never had anybody ask me this question.
It's a great question.
You could make this into a hot tea.
For sure.
That's just fine.
I never thought I'm doing that.
But you certainly can.
So there's no problem with that.
Let us know how it tastes.
Next question.
What does it mean when I have high vitamin B12 on my blood test?
This is a common question when I'm going over somebody's blood work.
Because it's a common physiological finding on blood work elevated B12.
OK, so most people think and many people have been told.
To stop taking their B12.
If they have elevated B12, I can't tell you how many times I've heard that.
My doctor told me to stop taking B12 because my blood serum B12 was elevated.
Or they just thought, well, I better stop taking the B12 that I'm taking because my B12 was elevated on my blood.
That's not correct thinking.
So let me explain why.
So B12 that you're going to take as a supplement or that you're going to consume as a food has to be absorbed.
And it's absorbed through a process of your stomach cells, the bridal cells of your stomach create and release this.
What we called intrinsic factor and B12 needs intrinsic factor to be absorbed in the cut.
So that touches to the B12 that you absorb the B12.
So if you have elevated serum B12 levels, that means you have adequate absorption of B12.
Many times it's because you're taking way too way more than a person needs.
But then you have elevated serum B12 levels. Is that a bad thing?
No, that's not a bad thing. Is there any harm in having elevated serum B12 levels? No, there's no harm in that.
But can that be an indication of something? It can.
So if a person is taking exogenous B12 supplementation and they have elevated B12.
Then they're, that's a good sign because they're making intrinsic factor. So they're absorbing most of what they're taking in that capsule or so they're getting it into their system.
But it can be a side.
If there's elevated serum B12 also of what's called a functional B12 deficiency because it's not getting into the tissues.
So elevated serum B12 and be a side of B12 deficiency in that it's not getting, it's a functional deficiency because it's not getting into the tissues.
So in that case, so whatever I see a blood test with somebody with elevated B12 and they say, should I stop taking B12 or my doctor told me to stop taking B12.
I said, no, keep taking B12 because you need that higher level of B12 circulating in your bloodstream to keep, you know, and fairly adequate amount of B12 in the tissues.
So there's no harm in having elevated serum B12, but it's usually a side of the person not having enough not getting into the tissues as well.
So they actually need to keep that serum B12 at an elevated level.
Now, if a person, that would absolutely be the case, if the person is saying, I don't have any supplements that I'm taking B12 as, you know, not taking a sublingual B12 because usually the B12s like we sell hydroxyl,
hydroxyl, cobalamine, which is a form of B12.
There's multiple different forms of B12.
Cobolamine is the B12 and it has to be bound to something. So if you get it as a supplement, it will be either cyanocobolamine, which I don't think that's a good form to take more synthetic form.
So I don't think anybody should take that.
Most supplements will be a methyl cobalamine and I don't think that's a good form to take for a cancer patient because you don't want excess metal groups.
If you have a diagnosis of cancer because excess metal groups will basically silence have the ability to silence to their suppressor gene.
You should be blocking the intrinsic a tonic pathway, so you shouldn't be taking methyl B12 as a cancer patient.
But most B12 supplementation out there is methyl B12.
So I would recommend if the person is deficient in B12, you should be taking a hydroxyl, cobalamine, or a denticel cobalamine.
And you should be taking it as a losage so that you're absorbing it sublingually through your mucus membranes and your mouth.
And because so many people have it, if they have a deficiency in B12, it's because they have a deficiency in the production of intrinsic factor by the bridal cells of the stomach.
And that's usually because they have hypochloridria.
So the creation of a intrinsic factor by the bridal cells of the stomach is completely dependent upon the pH of the stomach.
So if you have an increase pH of the stomach, we need a decrease hydrochloric acid, which is hypochloridria, you're going to have a decreased production of intrinsic factor and you're setting yourself up for a B12 deficiency, which is a type of anemia.
So you end up with a B12 anemia.
So that's all circulated back to hypochloridria being a major cause at B12 anemia.
But the question was about high B12. So high B12 is typically funded somebody who's taking B12 supplementation.
And then there it could be a functional issue because they're not getting as much B12 into the tissues, which would be a reason why you should keep taking B12.
Because there's no harm in keeping the high syrup level of B12.
You can have other issues with B12 having to elevated B12 with other conditions like chronic my low prolific disorders, a person can have diabetes that can show elevated B12 heart failure can show an elevated B12 obesity aids and others.
You know, serious liver conditions can show a elevated B12. So again, one blood test gives you clues to look at other things.
So you don't just look at, oh, I just have elevated B12. Where is my other, where are my other markers in relation to functional slash optimal ranges not just lab ranges.
So again, you look at a blood test in correlation with other signs and symptoms and other objective and subjective data in order to arrive at a clinical diagnosis.
That was a lot of words to answer that question. Sorry. Next cleaning. I'm cleaning my personal care items also include no hair.
So I think the question is, as I clean up my personal care items, should I also be looking at my hair coloring. Yes. So chemicals.
You women are more assaulted by cancer-causing chemicals than men are because women are going to be more have more of a tendency to use lotions and creams and certainly cosmetics.
And there's some of the most cancer-causing things. There's an interview somewhere on our blog post. I'm interviewing, I can't remember the guy's name. I'm so sorry.
But a gentleman over in Europe, I think he was in France and he's a specialist in environmental toxins. And especially was it pertains to personal care items. And he told me that there's 1300 different chemicals that are banned in these areas.
The chemicals that are banned in the European Union that are permitted in the United States that are in our personal care item products. There are all carcinogens 1300 different carcinogens that they can make personal care products without and they do and they sell them in Europe without it.
If they make it with it, I don't know, it may make it more creamy or colorful or whatever, but it's toxic and it's a carcinogenic and yet we are being exposed to it.
So yes, women especially have to go through their personal care products because when I say men don't have as many personal care products.
And then you talk about cleaning up your home like your cleaning products, your things that you wash your clothes and things that you wash your dishes and things that you use for dish washing detergent, things that you clean the floor with.
You're exposed, those things are you're exposed to those toxins, they they they have to you remember anything that you absorb any which way but lose into your system.
If you don't detoxify it, it becomes a part of you and it settles and sells and it can be a cancer causing them worse and other things too.
So crosses the blood brain barrier, it causes inflammation in the brain, it causes early dementia, all these different things. So the more you can clean up the environment, the better you can do.
I've been doing high dose IV vitamin C treatments, but I feel I need to take a break as my veins are harder to access.
I read that the supplement of a lesto, which is a brand of extensive and can be equivalent to the IVs are you familiar with this. Yes, I am familiar with that.
And it's and I have one other person right now that I know of that is taking that that he has a basal cell carcinoma that he's taking the topical form of that and he feels like he's it's helping the last time I talked to him.
He's had a switch to a lot of different topical forms, different supplements because something will work for a period of time and it stops working and he switches right now he's on that and he's thinking that it's helpful.
So how helpful do you think IV vitamin C is for treating or battling cancer?
I think it's fair, it can be very helpful but so can everything right so certainly if you feel like you need to take a break just like any supplement protocol you're on and taking a break from something is really a formal pulsing it so doesn't mean that you won't go back to it at some point in time but taking a break for three or four months can be beneficial to see help.
It can also be beneficial so that your body doesn't get used to that and then it has no benefits so there can you know we have other benefits other than just giving your veins are asked to take it a break for something.
You're also this person who's asking this question is doing a lot of other things so you can't possibly do everything out there it's not it would not be good for you to do everything out there you would overwhelm your liver would kill you defeated everything out there so you.
There's nothing wrong with with you know praying about your decision making process and making the decision to stop doing something for a short period of time maybe forever but you your there's nothing wrong with stopping.
I had elevated ebb and that's empty bar virus it's antimony so empty bar virus ebb antimony's IGG and my blood test is there a rife program for that yes there are rife programs and both the true rife and the Italian Robin for empty bar virus however so when you do.
The the empty bar virus blood test you're going to get you have the choice of running different antibody panels you could do with IGG IGM IGA panel I think only IGG and IGM for it I'm state bar to what is the difference.
And if I have elevated IGG antibodies for empty bar does that mean I have empty bar should I run a rife program for empty bar I have IGG antibodies most likely not so when you have what you're exposed to an antigen so when you're exposed to a pathogen of some kind.
And if you're exposed to a pathogen of virus empty bar virus your body how your immune system works is you'll fire a immediate response immune system response is called your th one response let's try to kill that pathogen and then if it can't kill it because it's very fairly very late or you have a heavy exposure that that th one response suppresses and your th two system fires or your B cell system fires.
And that's the purpose of that is not necessarily to kill anything it's creating antibodies so it's creates antibodies against that thing if you can think of antibodies as like fluorescent tape that it tapes on that pathogen so that now the th two system race suppresses in the th one system fires again and those are your natural killer cells and
macrophages and and T cells and they now can find that pathogen because it's tagged with this antibody is fluorescent tape so now they can find it and adequately kill it.
And there's a benefit of now having circulated fluorescent tape for that pathogen so that now maybe it adequately your body adequately killed it now you don't have any but if we measured your blood you'd still show positive antibodies.
So if you ever are exposed to that pathogen again now you these antibodies that are circulating in your bloodstream will take it immediately so now you'll maybe just be able to fire a th one response only and you'll kill it right away and you'll never really get sick that's what having a healthy immune response is I was exposed to strap as a young person a lot.
I developed a lot of antibodies and now my kids have strap you know and I don't get sick why do moms and dads lots times don't even get sick why because they have this mom power or something no because they have these antibodies that are already in their system so that they're you know they you know when they are exposed to that strap.
It gets tagged with that fluorescent strip aka antibody so that their immune system fires immediately kills it and they don't get sick quote unquote they were still sick they just didn't have the expression of prolonged illness because their immune system did its job and destroyed it because they had circulated antibodies for these days so really when we say I have a strong immune system you're saying I have a lot of circulated antibodies for a lot of different pathogens.
You want to and this is the danger i've said for decades about taking your kid to always got an ear infections you're going to run off and get antibiotics or he's got a stomach ache so you're going to run off and get some antibiotics are going to take it you know a medication to deal with the symptoms instead of allowing them to go through this normal immune response of a th one.
th two response where you actually create antibodies you want your child to create antibodies so that now they won't get sick three weeks from now and another strap goes around the school so the strength of a person's immune health is dependent upon the number of types of antibodies they have for different pathogens.
Now that being said how you would measure whether you have an acute infection of something or not there's different types of antibodies so IGG antibodies are significant to tell a person that they have had exposure to a pathogen but most likely don't have current active.
Antigen. So IGG antibodies tell us that you were exposed to Epstein bar virus sometime in your life you've developed antibodies these are the IGG antibodies that will take if you get exposed to it again tomorrow but it doesn't mean that you have an active infection so there really wouldn't be a need to run a right program for it nor would there be a need to run out and get some
decadation or garlic or whatever you're going to try to do to kill this virus IGG the presence of IGG antibodies typically just tell us that you had a past exposure now again I get a blood test you look at it with subjective and objective data correlated with other things the person is ready to fever they feel sick there have all these other symptoms maybe they're only showing IGG antibodies.
Typically though you'd run it IGG IGM pedal and if a person had an active pathogen they'd have elevated IGM antibodies so that's really what you look at so I talk to people all the time that say oh my gosh my doctor's treating me for Epstein bar oh why here's the test they show me the test or they have negative IGM antibodies and they have positive IGG antibodies
they're on decision making clinical decision making there that most likely that person has just had past exposure if they do not have a current infection there's no need to treat them
for a current infection of Epstein bar virus when they show negative IGM antibodies and positive IGG antibodies so hopefully that clears that up.
Next question, I have heard that increased you know sinophils means I have allergies is that true possibly yeah so yes sinophils are a type of white blood cell when you get your CBC done you want to get a CBC with differential most clinics are never going to run a CBC without ready to get
differential mean a differential means we're differentiating between the types of white blood cells that we're measuring so now I have seen especially in a hospital setting where they'll somebody goes into the emergency room and they just run a simple you know some simple metabolic panel it's like good mistakes and then they charge a person's insurance you know $1,000
for this $5 test it's absolutely ridiculous and you don't run a differential makes absolutely no sense if you're going to do a CBC without running a differential so the differential splits out the white blood cells into you know it's major components there's you could split it out much deeper and do it a whole lymphocyte panel but it splits it out into its major components what's how many lymphocytes actually absolute is called the
the numbers that they count in the slide that they're looking at and then percentage so you typically the differential you'll have lymphocytes neutrophils, basophils, esinophils, monocytes and then it'll give a absolute value and a percentage value so if you have an increased absolute value and an increased percentage value of one of those things it gives you clues to why
the white blood cell count may be elevated or you could even have a normal white blood cell count you could have an abnormal differential so on these we've discussed the differentials on the white blood cells with neutrophils before typically if you have an elevated neutrophil it may be significant that you have a bacterial infection it typically if you have an elevated lymphocyte it may be more
critical that you have a viral infection if you have an elevated esinophil does that mean that you have an allergy it can be that's one of the things that it can be so food allergies environmental allergies you know person that has really bad environmental allergies let's say pollen allergies can have an elevated esinophil at that time of the year so that can be significant but also intestinal parasites can increase esinophils
and then people with allergic type conditions like asthma can have an elevated esinophil so just like any of the other differential components it's it's not a perfect science like oh you have this then you have this you know you have to correlate it with other things let's say the person you know we we did a stool sample test today
they have no intestinal parasites send no symptoms of intestinal parasites but they you know they have signs and symptoms of allergies then you make then you might
correlating with that's probably what it's coming from and then that would certainly spark you to maybe we should run a food panel or maybe we should do this or whatever
but even with most foods you sense tibities and such you don't see acute uprise any esinophils unless it's an acute condition and remember you're drawing this blood at just one specific
time of the day that you're drawing to you know this pile of blood out of a person's arm so it really depends on what's going on specifically at that time with that
that time with that individual so it's not elevating the esinophils.uncommon but it's certainly not common and so you would look you just it was spark you to look for the reason why but the biggest reasons why I mean intestinal parasites food sensitivities
environmental sensitivities is some sort of allergic condition going on maybe even a hypersense typer mass cell response at that particular time asthma something like that you'd be looking at those possibilities.
You mentioned running cyrex tests before which one would be good for a cancer patient so it really depends so remember just because the person has cancer doesn't mean they don't have other comorbidities
and they may have other comorbidities that could kill them before the cancer so you do want to you know not not address those things
but the cyrex testing is antibody testing most of the cy well we run cyrex tests were testing for antibodies that's why we use the cyrex labs they do have some other lymphocyte panels and stuff that we don't use as much but typically we're using cyrex to run antibody tests
why would a cancer patient want to run antibody tests well multiple reasons if you're looking for the health of the got then you would run cyrex array 2 which is going to test for got permeability factors
so remember there's three different levels of leaky gutter got permeability so we would want to see you know what level of got permeability this person is dealing with if they have got problems
we can see and four tell us breakdown gliaden which is the protein of gluten into its components the peptide components and we're measuring if the person has antibodies to that
and certain the gliaden peptide issues are common with cancer which are commonly lead to hyper inflammatory responses elsewhere their body
and remember if you have food antibodies if you're every time you eat something that you don't even know you have an antibody to you're going to cause this inflammatory response in the gut
and now you have your immune system fighting battles at other fronts so it's like okay if we would have went into world war two in Japan would have never attacked us and they were going to be our allies and friends and we were fighting Hitler
it would have been a lot weaker to come to the conclusion of defeating the Nazis because we wouldn't have been split trying to fight the battle at two fronts
well same thing with our body if we have food antibodies that were not aware of and every time we eat that food it's causing inflammatory response in the gut the immune system is having to split its forces instead of trying to just kill the cancer
it's dealing with this inflammatory response in the gut and it certainly would be beneficial if we could rule things out and clean things up and help heal the gut that's why we have most of you people on a drink mix that is got a lot of gut healing things in there as well
and supporting detoxification pathways and supporting gut health so that we can calm that down but to run Syrex panels to test for that and to kind of clean that up and discover what I need to change
for that aspect I'd say array two array three array four array ten so that's where we get into really the gut healing things for to help call that inflammatory response in the gut
and then if you want to look at other comorbidities do I have antibodies to other tissues that I'm you know have autoimmune diseases that are yet diagnosed that I've never discovered because I then looking at array five which tests a lot of antibodies to different tissues and array seven X which gets into details of antibodies to neurological tissue
then you could do array 11 and array 12 which is I don't run those very often that's if you have antibodies to different toxins and different pathogens
they don't run those very often because they I don't think that they really give us the big they tell us a lot but they don't like give us how to treat that you're already kind of treating that so it to me you run a lab if it's going to really change the way you're going to care for the patient
not just to gain information so that's what I would look at what is the best thing to do for dizziness or dizziness but like any symptom you always want to ask that hunting question of why so why you'll have dizziness that's what you want to treat you don't want to just treat the dizziness
why is it there so you know you do a differential diagnosis diagnostic workup on a person that has a symptom like that I have dizziness well when do you have dizziness is it when you stand from city down
when you get up out of bed is it no you know it's just the different times I just feel off a dizzy those the answers to those questions are going to pinpoint us in different directions
first I'm going to have dizziness because of neurological you know issues they could even have you know need a little carpenter get their neck adjusted that could be an issue.
But you start thinking about circulatory things with dizziness as well you think of neurological inflammation with dizziness that's common
if they have dizziness upon a rising and then it calms down right away I just have to hold myself when I stand up you start thinking of adrenal insufficiency because your adrenals are supposed to kick in and raise your blood pressure about 10 points from a city to a standing position
so you can easily measure that if you have a really good blood pressure cuff measure my blood pressure city down I stand up and measure keeping the cuff on measure right away again blood pressure drops or does not rise 10 points
then that's an adrenal insufficiency test so that could be it could be a blood sugar problem that's a common issue for dizziness people with diabetes and blood pressure blood sugar issues can have dizziness
so you have to figure out why is what I'm saying so it's not a matter of oh is there a program for dizziness on the right I'm just going to run that well now you're going to you're going to get to the reason why if you would be to run some tests to do that or at least answer some questions to try to figure out
you used to say you insist on a Tesla bulb for the right is that's still the case or have you changed your mind on that
so a Tesla bulb is simply just another term for a gas filled bulb or a plasma bulb there isn't a right you know there isn't a bulb that true right sells or that we sell that isn't that that's what what are we say you're buying a bulb or a tube or a plasma tube that's a Tesla tube that they're all that they're all the same
the peptide therapy includes the following peptides so so the peptide therapy includes the following includes the following the poly lysede is the only peptide in that group so understand poly lysede is the peptide the
are to miss it is are to miss it that's an herb IP 6 is IP 6 that's a component to minerals in a certain form in an IP 6 excels structure
glutathione is glutathione NAD is precursor to nitric oxide is nitric oxide stimulator and colloidal silver so the treatment in this peptide therapy as far as quality of peptide therapy is the poly lysede the other ones are something different
again I personally would not recommend glutathione for a cancer patient or NAD for cancer patients and the poly lysede is the peptide in the peptide therapy is still a question for me but again that's you know that's something you're going to have to make a decision on rather than be an oxidative doesn't this more like an antioxidant can there be a place for antioxidants
that some cancer protocols yes there can be a place for antioxidants and cancer protocols and not everybody agrees with me that you shouldn't be generically just doing you know not doing antioxidants it's just the more I've learned the more I've studied the more experience that I've had
you know for nine out of 10 people that we test do not test well with antioxidants it's literally 10% of my patient base that have ever come to me have we that have cancer that we put them on little time and I don't think anybody's tested for NAD
that your coxid the negative of nitric oxide stimulation is not antioxidant versus pro oxidative therapy it's that it stimulates veg F production so that's vascular endothelium growth factor so I'd say if a person theoretically if a person has a blood cancer a leukemia
then I don't see a problem with the NAD if you have a hard cancer we need a you know a tumor type cancer then I will again there's no way I would use nitric oxide stimulators because that isn't going to increase the
excursation of that tumor and increase the survival factor of that tumor so I have no idea why that clinic is doing that no idea why the clinic is just standardly used include a thigh only that's just my tank you can disagree with me think people can
agree with me that's just my understanding so any other questions alright well thank you guys for being on tonight remember I'll put up any notices or any changes in the member site and always you know great to get your questions in and we'll see you
so you are best to get advanced here we'll pray for all you guys alright bye bye